me now joining me now for reaction White
House counselor to the president excuse
me my friend of too many years to count
Kellyanne Conway all right Kellyanne
this is wild I mean I've never seen this
I've been in this town for 30 years you
escape to New York for a while but I've
been in this town for a long time
an anonymous staffer strikes up some
relationship with the New York Times and
know they're convinced to pen this op-ed
what are your thoughts I'm not sure it
matters there are op-eds like that in
the New York Times every day it's just a
different byline or I guess an on by
line here I just have to correct the
record it's not clear to us anyway that
it's somebody in the White House so
they're saying senior administration
official that could be many people there
I think thousands of political
appointees hundreds of folks who would
qualify under that title alone but to
your point presidents aren't judged by
the noise or even the silence that's
occurring at any one moment or any one
week by the usual critics and they say
they're judged by the metrics and when I
hear people on cable news even taking
your montage I confess I hadn't seen any
of it before now I say words like
historic unprecedented stunning that's
exactly the way we describe the economy
exactly we describe the way he's chopped
down all the overburden some duplicate
duplicate of and unnecessary regulations
he this is a historically and on
historic and unprecedented economic boom
time and the Democrats would take that
away and and he knows that because you
saw the president today respond the way
many of us who had the privilege of
working in the White House see him
respond all the time not fuming not
infuriated not isolated he took it right
to what was already a planned event with
the sheriff's
Hurra lined up there to thank this
president for being pro law enforcement
to making sure they have the resources
and respect they deserve and he took it
out of his pocket and he read his
statement and he pushed back on this
op-ed any of this again any of it any of
the things that are in this op-ed ring
true at all in the slightest
what rings true to me is that people are
trying to I'll have it both ways they
want to serve in the government they're
pretending that they're somehow
protecting the country from Donald Trump
you see that all throughout the Woodward
book
of staffing we have a very small
presidential personnel office compared
to Obama I think half the staffers last
time I checked I know Johnny just a good
guy it really depends on his other words
it depends who it is but we've always
been concerned from the beginning that
there were people in this administration
who did not buy into the Trump agenda
look down upon it thought we can we can
thwart the agenda whether it's the wall
or and they're kind of laughing at the
agenda and I was worried about it a lot
of like-minded people who are when I
hear him the very beginning we're very
worried I'm still worried about it I
hear you I would got an op-ed in the New
York Times yes indeed and it really
depends who it is but I also think
that's not particularly relevant but I
meaning like who it is but what I want
to say is it could be someone in the
West Wing it's just it could be here's
what I'm going to say about all of that
that would be a huge problem but here's
what I want to say about all that it's
that the president said that means today
I thought it really rang true he said
the New York Times had apologized to its
readers because they've got the election
so wrong he's got a good point which is
it's still not clear that many who cover
him every day and criticize him thusly
understand how he got here and what he's
done since he got here and what it all
means to people and that's incredibly
important because look at the
histrionics on Capitol Hill yesterday
look at the difference between people
trying to protest and disrupt but we're
getting into that a hearing well a
hearing for an Emily qualified
individual who today basically schooled
some of the senator his own constitution
and the point I'm making too is who put
him there that is the promise of our own
decision making processes and so and and
speaking of the speaker Ryan and leader
McConnell they were at the White House
today and you know what came of it you
know it came to these meetings that
they're going to the house is going to
vote on making permanent the individual
tax cut so the people saying oh they
should evoke this amendment that they're
actually continuing with the President's
agenda they know it's worth this
drumbeat and it's with Woodward who is
one you know when every journalistic
awards well respected by the way did you
see this like your mention in this
Woodward deal I don't know if you guys
caught the annotation is this is the one
of the goofiest goofiest things I have
ever seen this is a transcript
of a call that says nothing where the
president is actually I think really
cool with Woodward saying well I'm not
gonna it's probably gonna be a lousy
book I'm not really that he's like
Kellyanne I think there's a part where
you talked about Kelly and it's like so
idiotic like who cares who it's so I got
to play for you something that that John
Kerry former Secretary of State
democratic obvious Obama said tonight on
CNN let's watch this is a genuine
constitutional crisis this is a moment
where it's a crisis of conscience for
people in the United States Senate on
the other side of the aisle where they
have been willing to be more protective
of their chairmanships of their party of
their president than they have of the
Constitution and the institutions
themselves constitutional crisis but you
see you see this building from whether
it's goofy Omarosa or Woodward to this
Michael Wolf that it goes on and on oh
look there are rumors that John Kerry
wants to run and loose again for
president that's his right it's a free
country he can do that he's over the age
of 35 go for it
Joe Biden wants to do the same thing you
saw a lot of the 20/20 aspirins
yesterday trying to embarrass Brett
Kavanaugh but they really embarrassed
themselves and the people who were there
protesting on their behalf and the one
thing I don't see in the Woodward book
which i think is very fascinating is
Russia collusion O'Kelly and why is that
relevant he didn't say he was out the
media has spent more time on that story
than anyone else but is it in there in
other words if you're if you're the if
you're a journalist who took down
Richard Nixon if you're deeply respected
in many corners in Washington DC wasn't
somebody who had evidence that come to
you wouldn't it leak out well no there's
no rush seclusion this is why they're
going but that's amendment so that's
actually important because I'm gonna say
why is she talking about that we're
talking about because they pivot because
when they have nothing to say they move
to the next you did an interview with
Woodward yes I did early on when he came
to the White House in very early on when
we got here what did you guys and then a
year and a half later or so I went to
have luncheon to find out about the book
and what else and and so but I'm of
course aboveboard about that right but I
said to the president you have the
president
about it about morning these I don't
like people who go to their car and
write memos to the file like homie I
don't like people who write anonymous op
eds because it's it's Loserville it's
people who are afraid to put their names
if you're a whistleblower you step
forward but that's why so much and you
actually use my mail
well that's right but so much of the
book is not new because it's the fourth
consecutive book that I can see where
certain people are trying to feed their
own emotions and egos about how
brilliant they were on the campaign and
when we form a White House and it's just
it's so that's a little tired but what I
what I wanted to tell you too is I think
in that call it's important because
whatever it says that he tried through
six or seven different people to get an
interview with the president and I would
so I said would you please give the
president all the names because the only
one he knows is mine and I don't think
that that's been revealed yet because of
course their sources for the book look
many of the accounts Izzo mazuma was the
first person account of some former
colleagues because that's very nice the
point is a lot of tips are disappointing
that some people went on the record and
they have but general Jones in Obama's
White House he left after the Woodward
book came out about called Obama's mores
because he was the NSA to use the
national security I get from the first
week the administration we're out of
time but first week the administration
there started to be leaks before it
actually two weeks before the
inaugurates leaked leaked leaked leaked
leaked Flynn stuff it like well the
leakers aren't difficult to them of the
administration that's how I feel about
this the leakers fall into two big
categories people who say they never
talked to me I hate the media oh I'm so
afraid to go on the Ingraham angle come
on how do you do it I can never talk
they talk to me all day long the other
categories people who never get bad
press
so obviously that would be you or me but
people never get bad press good leakers
Kelly oh thank you to check the source
again you got it for coming in thank you
I thought I thought was of just a
fascinating conversation with Bob
Woodward think of him a page of this
ridiculous you and I are not anonymous
yeah exactly